[Music]
people who play with a finite mindset
all the planning comes in the past and
what they're trying to do is avoid any
surprises be prepared for every surprise
so whether it's in in battle or whether
it's in sports the reason we train and
train and train and train and train is
so that we are prepared for every
eventuality we can avoid surprises but
that's not where innovation happens
because all the thinking has already
happened an infinite mindset embraces
surprise the thinking hasn't happened
yet the thinking is yet to happen it's
when we when something new happens or
we're in a new situation now we have to
think our way imagine our way create our
way into a new path out of this box this
is a magical time this is a time that
accentuates creativity this is the value
of things that are uncertain this is the
value of things that happen unexpectedly
they force us it forts us forces us to
be creative now many people shut down
because what we've learned isn't working
anymore that's where the shutdown comes
from the infinite mindset embraces that
which is uncertain that which is
indifferent that's what it means to have
an infinite mindset so now is a perfect
perfect time it's a perfect opportunity
to embrace exactly what's happening how
will you reinvent the future how will
you take what you know how will you take
the things that you want to achieve and
adapt imagine if you were starting from
scratch today that the world that will
be the world that is is the world that
always was it's like a start-up
mentality you know which is a forget how
things were what the plan was but if you
were starting from scratch right now how
would you bring your talents your gifts
your entrepreneurial spirit to life how
do you leverage your relationships how
do you form relationships how do we take
care of the people around us which is
another important point which is the
tenets of good leadership are more
relevant now than ever before
it's always been important for us to
check in on our people make sure they're
okay be open to people checking in on us
and just being open and honest about how
we feel and now during these strange
times we have to reach out to our
friends not during not with a text not
with an email but preferably with a
phone call or a video conference
something where they can hear the tone
of voice I actually find phone calls to
be even better than video conferences
because we're not just looking at a
screen staring at ourselves let's be
honest we
look at ourselves but actually we can be
completely present in the tone of voice
that someone has on the other side of
the phone as opposed to pretending to
make eye contact with them by staring at
the camera or worrying about our haircut
or looking at them which is not really
looking at them tone of voice matters we
can create human relationships that way
and so we should be doubling down on
checking in with people we should be
doubling down with calling them one by
one and saying are you okay these are
the basic tenets of leadership and to
practice them now when in times of
stress and anxiety
hopefully we'll carry those good habits
with us when we return to new abnormal
so congratulations to all of you I want
you to see the opportunity and the
advantages in the world you graduating
in to wish you best of luck or as my dr.
James Carson used to wish his students
wishing you bad luck because that's when
you're gonna learn things if everything
goes right you won't let anything so
wishing you old bad luck you said it
sounds weird really weird to say but
wishing you creativity innovation and
and lots of deep meaningful relationship
take care of yourself take care of each
other and congratulations again
[Music]